I thought for once I'd talk about my own science. Yeah.
Which I don't usually do. I usually talk about more general things in science,
but I talk about some of the research that I've been doing,
or actually perhaps more correctly.
Some of the research that mostly Tom Pitkin he's my PhD student has been doing
time.
Slicing times, slicing spiral.
Galaxies with SDSs, for manga. What does that.
Mean? Where do we start to tell the story?
We probably need to back up a bit and talk a little bit about galaxies.
Here's a couple of galaxies, a couple of nice spiral galaxies,
and we can come back to talk a little bit about what the hexagons mean,
but for the moment, just look at the pictures of the galaxies.
Probably the most telling difference between these two pictures is that one of
them is blue and the other isn't stars are different.
Masses have different colors. The most massive stars tend to be blue.
And then the less massive stars tend to be red.
So whenever you see blue light that tells you there are massive stars there,
which means that the stars must have formed recently,
a blue color tells you that a galaxy is actively forming stars and a red color
tends to tell you that it probably isn't so accurately forming stars.
What slightly complicates the story is that there are other things that can make
galaxies blue or red as well. So for example, if a galaxy appears red,
it could be that it's intrinsically blue,
but there's a whole load of this dusty material between you and the galaxy and
dust tends to absorb the blue light, but let the red light through.
So you end up just seeing the red light. So it could be a dusty galaxy.
The other possibility is it could be a galaxy that has a lot of heavy elements
in it, in that heavy elements, absorb light at different parts of the spectrum.
And they tend to be better at absorbing blue light than they are at absorbing
red light. So therefore you end up absorbing a bunch of them,
of the blue light that would have been emitted, but you still see the red light.
Fortunately,
you can do a bit better than just looking at the colors and in particular,
you can split the whole thing up into the complete spectrum so that all the
colors of the rainbow and study in detail,
what the light is at different wavelengths.
Here's an example of what happens when you do that.
And this is looking at different stellar populations,
and there are different things in here that there are different ages of stellar
populations, and there are different amounts of heavy elements,
but the only things really to take away from this is,
so this is basically how much light there is as a functional wavelength,
starting at the blue end of the spectrum,
and ending up at the red end of the spectrum. So this is the intensity of light,
it's kind of a continuum.
And then there was these little dips and very specific wavelengths.
And these dips aware some particular chemical elements is absorbing star light.
So this whole very kind of regular series of lines here, for example,
all due to hydrogen. And as I say,
these different lines are for different assumes ages and different assumed heavy
element abundances, and they're all different.
So you can actually sort of disentangle the, all these different effects.
So if you were to, to take the spectrum of a galaxy,
you could actually use this kind of information to tell what,
why the galaxy was red,
white with blue and sort of distinguished between these different effects.
One of the games we can now play,
are we things called integral field units or use where instead of taking one
spectrum at a time,
you take a whole bunch of spectra from all across the face of a galaxy.
So we can do this kind of across an entire galaxy, all in one go.
And so actually this hexagon on these pictures are sort of the footprint of the
area where we've actually been playing this game.
And the reason why it's a hexagon is because the way that this is actually done
in practice for this particular survey is that there's a whole bunch of optical
fibers, which have been arranged in a hexagonal pattern.
And each of those fibers captures a little bit of light and gets fed into a
spectrograph and the spectrograph records, the spectrum.
So essentially we can kind of recall the spectrum at every point across the
entire face of the galaxy. And so this is actually a survey,
it's this thing called manga.
It's a project I've been involved in for a number of years. Now.
There's hundreds of astronomers involved in it as part of an even bigger project
called the Sloan digital sky survey. The mango project is doing this,
essentially,
this recording spectral all across the face of galaxy for 10,000 galaxies.
So that's one part of the thing that's new that we can actually do this kind of
analysis across entire galaxies at a time, the other bit that's new.
And the bit that my PhD student Tom's been working on is that what he's been
able to show is that actually you can do better than just saying,
is it this or this in that this assumes that the gut, you know, the,
all the stars of the galaxy are one age, right?
They're all 10 billion years old, or they're all a billion years old, of course,
in a real galaxy. That's not what happens in a real galaxy.
There's some stars which are young stumps stars, which are,
middle-aged some stars which are old.
And of course the light you get from them will just be the sum of all those
different spectrum. What we've been able to show you can kind of disentangle it,
which means that you can take a spectrum and say, ah,
this bit of the galaxy is 30% old star, 60% middle-aged stars,
uh, and the remaining 10% young stars or something like that.
So you can actually disentangle all these different things.
And that's this thing called time slicing that essentially we take the whole
galaxy and say, okay, so 10% of the light is young,
this mildly middle-aged and so on,
we can actually go through the entire life history of the galaxy and kind of
speak it up into his parts. So the actually is for this gallery,
one of those galaxies I showed you before, this actually is this galaxy.
It has a very uninspiring name in, uh, the pollens of this survey.
It's eight three, two nine miners one, two seven Oh one. It needs a name.
What's the student's name again? Tom Peter kin.
Pizza gins, galaxy tuck-ins galaxy. There you go. That's better.
Here.
We all going through and slicing through the galaxy from the oldest stars to the
youngest star. So we start with the oldest stars here in the middle,
and then we go through middle-aged stars, youngest stars.
So the first thing says formal right in the middle,
very centrally concentrated over time.
It grew outwards form this disc around it.
And then the latest stars with seeing now forming in this moment,
arms that's when you start happening at spiral arm. Exactly.
So it's actually telling you,
this is where star formation is happening now because actually that's the
strong, most intense star formation happens in the spiral and arms.
The other interesting piece of information to remember, I said,
not only do you get the ages of the stars,
but you get to learn about what their heavy element abundances are as well.
And the slightly sort of counter-intuitive thing is the color coding here is
basically telling you what the heavy element of abundance is,
are in that the reddest colors of the highest heavy element abundance and the
blue is colors are the lowest heavy element abundances.
And so what you can actually see is that those first stars to form is quite red.
And so they have a lot of heavy elements in them.
Now that doesn't seem to make much sense, because remember I said,
the way you get the heavy elements is by having success in generations of stars.
And yet you to thought the first thing stars to form the Cod have been
successive generations of stars to make that happen.
What this is telling you is that in that inner region,
the must've been very quick turnaround and making lots and lots of stars and
many generations of stars very quickly to kind of crank up that heavy element
abundance. And then as the thing we're outwards,
you're making more and more stars out of more and more kind of pristine
material. That's falling into the galaxy. That's,
hasn't been through so many generations of stars.
So that I guess probably is not something you would have sort of assumed if you
hadn't actually seen the picture here,
you might have assumed that the stuff in the middle she'd have the lowest heavy
element abundance. Whereas actually,
this is telling you that the story is a bit more complicated than that.
And actually there must've been lots of generations of stars.
And it's just telling you that the stars are being made from new material coming
from outside. Not what's been sped up by the old dead guys for the most part.
Although it doesn't have zero chemical and heavy element abundances.
So it's sort of telling you that there must've been some processing within the,
this, but actually it's more pristine. It's, it's, it's,
it's more kind of new gas falling in. That's making the,
those outer parts of the galaxy,
the technical aspects of doing this is quite difficult in that you've somehow
this, this aspect of it,
of disentangling all those different components to figure out uniquely what the
thing was made of is actually really quite technically challenging and
complicated.
So a lot of the process has been going through a lot of testing to say,
you know, if we make an,
make a galaxy ourselves where we know what the components are,
and then we kind of sort of pretend to observe it and add a bit of noise as we
would actually get in a real galaxy, can we then get back out what we put in,
in the first place?
And so there's a lot of testing you need to go through in order to do this,
to convince yourself, you really are doing this slicing things up in time,
rather than just randomly fitting company.
If you have a Jetta material coming out of the center of galaxy and it starts to
wiggle around, that's probably this Kelvin Helmholtz instability as well.
It's basically wherever you have two streams of material traveling at different
speeds. This instability will kick in.